so I was laying in bed the other night
when I started to think about voice
adoption in writing and presentation
it's this phenomenon that tons of people
have noticed where if you spend a lot of
time listening to a distinct speech
pattern or reading a distinct style then
you can get into a zone where you think
and write and even speak in that voice
tons of people know about this but if
there's a word for this phenomenon I
have never heard it and it is not
impossible to look up so we're going to
call it voice adoption except that just
runs us into another problem the word
voice voice refers to both the physical
sound that comes out of a person that
sounds aesthetic qualities and it refers
to the way that individuals or groups
use language that's kind of weird
right I mean this sound coming out of my
noise box is very very different thing
from my patterns of word choice and yet
they both use the same word at the very
least it would appear that voices may be
the umbrella term and the two related
but very distinct ideas are encompassed
by it like you have a sandwich and the
sandwich is made out of various
ingredients but in this case the
sandwiches voice and we don't have a
distinct word for the ingredients
writers voice comes close but seems to
be struggling with the same lack of a
word it is a phrase that gestures in the
direction of the idea this application
of language as opposed to the execution
of speaking and says you know that that
thing with with the stuff with the when
people write it's obvious the bad you
know what I'm talking about so if I want
to talk specifically about the one then
I need to spend several paragraphs
explaining just what exactly it is that
I'm rattling on about in the first place
sure we could just make a new word but
have you ever tried to make a new word
it's really hard see up above we made a
potentially new ish word by referring to
an idea as voice adoption pulling to
existing ideas together to form a new
thing if we were speaking German then
would even smash the two together into a
single written word without any spaces
but what if there isn't a handy similar
word that we can adopt or combine well
the next habit is to look to other
nearby languages or parent languages and
pillage words or parts of speech and in
this specific case we get lucky because
it turns out that Latin already roughly
differentiated between these
with the words sonís to refer to the
sound of something and modis to refer to
the style or method which are the
component parts of Vox or voice another
common example that you've probably
heard before the English word love
encompasses six different Greek words
eros Philae a ludus agape pragma and
Philo gia the last one being further
split into the ideas of narcissism and
self esteem but that's a pretty straight
line English already uses a lot of Greek
and Latin word parts sonís in sonorant
and sonnet modus is the M in mo modus
operandi the Greek eros Philae and
pragma erotic hydrophilic and pragmatic
sometimes though you're backed into a
corner and need a word for a concept
that Greek and Latin don't really deal
with you might get lucky and there's a
great word in another language that just
fits right into English like
schadenfreude pleasure derived from the
misfortune of others or you might get
unlucky and there's a perfect word like
the Japanese boquete Oh which is the act
of staring vacantly into the distance
but it doesn't quite fit English grammar
he was boquete Oh Inge he was boquete oh
I'm just going to stand here and boquete
oh well let's call that one a half fit
all right so why care so much about
words because words are the way we
translate thoughts into communication
and if we don't have a word for
something then it's really hard to talk
about it to illustrate in English these
boxes are different shades of the same
color
however in Hebrew Russian and Italian
they are different colors entirely we
need a word to express a thought and the
words that we have available then
feedback and shape the way that we think
about things for a very present example
in videogames look no further than
arguments about what is and is not a
game well the argument is in many ways
protectionist and exclusion is two
specific slivers of culture the
existence of the argument belies the
fact that game as a word lacks the
nuance that we conceptually recognize
like the difference between taco and
hoagie both being types of sandwich
there is something recognizable but
difficult to fully describe the
differentiates a play for fun and
competition and maybe some story game
from a play for story and lyrical
experience
and self-reflection game so maybe that's
the challenge I can leave with you dig
up Boros scrounge or invent new words
for these ideas if you have any ideas
put them in the comments but either
which way go in peace my children in the
name of like share and subscribe
amen